الى اوكرانيا حيث يتجدد اللغط بشان هجوم
كييف المضاد بعد ترجيح مسؤولين روس
وغربيين انه بدا بالفعل وفي هذا السياق
قال لنا وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو عن
احباط محاوله للقوات الاوكرانيه لاختراق
خطوط دفاعات القوات الروسيه في محور زبون
وصف شيغو الهجوم بالمفاجئ وغير المسبوق
حاول اللواء الالي الاوكراني 47 الليله
الماضيه اختراق خطوط دفاعات القوات
الروسيه في محور زابولوجيا بفضل
الاستخبارات تم الكشف في الوقت المناسب عن
تحركات العدو وتوجيه ضربه استباقيه له
بمساعده المدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات تم ايقاف العدو في
الاتجاهات الاربعه وخسر 30 دبابه واحدى
عشره عربه مشاه ونحو 350 من قواته خلال
معارك اليوم الماضي خسر العدو اكثر من 900
عسكري
وثلاثه وثلاثين دبابه واكثر من 25 عربه
مشاه وثلاثه مدفعيات واسلحه اخرى
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقاطع فيديو
قالت انها تظهر تدمير دبابات واليات
اوكرانيه خلال صد القوات الروسيه للهجوم
الاوكراني في زابولوجيا وتظهر الصور تعرض
رتل من الدبابات للقصف